ferrell salmacis bonjour merci d'avoir
accepté notre invitation à matinale de
rtl france alors pour bien comprendre
ces subventions pour les artistes à qui
elles sont destinées et très
concrètement
bonjour merci l'invitation alors ces
subventions donc elles vont elles sont
confiées un institut culturel dirigé par
quinquas qui est un fidèle de viktor
orban qui est ouvertement quelqu'un en
faveur de mr bones donc on peut
évidemment comprendre que ce soit remis
en question mais en réalité
pourquoi est-ce que des subventions de
la culture pose problème pourquoi est ce
que dans ce cas là ça devient un sujet
dont on parle même à l'étranger
évidemment tout ça s'inscrit dans un
contexte plus vaste qui est celui de la
halle à ce qu'on appelle la guerre
culturelle de viktor orban
c'est à dire que viktor orban essaie de
consolider une une culture une éducation
qui soit plutôt dit de droite alors que
le monde culturel est éminemment à
gauche on va dire si on simplifie les
choses
donc oui c'est pas les mêmes
financements que d'habitude
ce qu'on voit notamment en occident mais
en réalité il n'y a pas de changement
majeur et je tiens à préciser le fait
qu' il y a une enveloppe particulière
débloqués pour ce fidèle de viktor orban
qui aura donc la mission de distribuer
sa des artistes non pas qu'ils soient
pas des critiques du gouvernement mais
qu'ils soient plutôt représentants de
comment dire est qu'ils soient plutôt en
qui représente des valeurs plutôt qui
intéresse le gouvernement
voilà le land promouvoir certaines
valeurs que s'il s'agit pas de soutenir
des partisans ou des militants
politiques de vite en sorbonne mais
plutôt des artistes qui font déjà
un travail qui ont une oeuvre qui va
dans le sens qui plaît au gouvernement
c'est comme pas tout à fait la même
chose
voilà alors on parle de ironiquement de
pop patriotique concrètement quels sont
les critères ont justement pour pour
adhérer à ces valeurs ont croisé est ce
que la population elle même est d'accord
avec ça oui alors évidemment lorsque ce
sujet est devenu lorsque ces subventions
est devenu un sujet d'actualité en parce
qu à l'étranger évidemment c'est
uniquement à travers des canaux hostiles
à viktor orban
donc c'est quelque chose qui a été
dénigré qui a été moquée alors vous avez
vous lu aime citer cette phrase qui ne
phrase clé qui est utilisé par les
médias libéraux
les artistes sont inquiets alors les
artistes anti or ban ouvertement anti
organes sont toujours subventionné
il n'y a aucun souci donc ils n'ont pas
vraiment de raison d'être inquiet être
jaloux peut-être ça c'est une autre
chose oui mais inquiets dont ils n'ont
pas de raison d'être inquiet et donc
votre question d'art dont c'était
certain sur quelles valeurs justement
est-ce que les criminels
alors peut-on dire que que tel ou tel
groupe en tout cas est plus en phase
avec les valeurs hongroise
tout à fait il y a il y à il ya
essentiellement des valeurs patriotiques
alors c'est presque un gros mot en
france mais il faut bien remettre les
choses dans le contexte la hongrie est
un pays post socialiste donc c'est un
pays de un ancien pays du bloc de l'est
dans lequel ce mot là n'a pas du tout la
même connotation le patriotisme et ce
qui a été le ciment pour reconstruire
une nation à la sortie du communisme
ce n'est pas du chauvinisme ce n'est pas
de la haine xénophobe c'est pas du
nationalisme virulent le patriotisme
c'est simplement le fait de devoir comme
on voit sur ces images en direct
on va vite en open qui porte la cocarde
c'est ce qu'on porte le 15 mars pour ce
pour commémorer la révolution de 1848
c'est le fait de respecter
le l'héritage de la nation respecter
certains symboles respecter tout un
ensemble de valeurs mais aussi mettre
promouvoir la langue hongroise
promouvoir le le la culture hongroise
dans tous ses aspects que ce soit la
gastronomie par exemple mais ou de les
mettre en avant les anciens poètes etc
bon enfin je sais vraiment rien de
particulier il faut vraiment pas y voir
là quelque chose de qui casse la baraque
1 c c'est pas ne se seraient pas bien
comme de la censure c'est ce que vous
voulez nous dire est ce que ce serait
valable également pour les pièces de
théâtre ou les concerts oui bien sûr ça
touche tous les aspects de sa touche
tous les arts maintenant la grande
difficulté c'est qu'on ne peut pas créer
ex nihilo des artistes on va dire qu'ils
font un certain certains types de neuf
ans donc ce que c'est pour ça que dans
c'est qu'il ya des débats en anglais
autour de ça parce qu'on dit oui mais du
coup cette somme là qui bosse et on
parle d'un euro ça doit faire environ 60
millions d'euros c'est l'heure de
grandeur 62 65
c'est bon c'est pas une somme
insignifiante mais c'est pas non plus
une somme délirante à l'échelle d'un
pays pour subventionner la culture
la hongrie n'a pas de ministère de la
culture d'accord donc les subventions
d'état à la culture qui sont quelque
chose de normal en occident puisqu'il ya
plus le mécénat comme il pouvait y avoir
avancé souvent c'est l'état maintenant
qui subventionne la culture maintenant
voilà comment un état comme un
gouvernement qui a un soutien populaire
important décide de subventionner la
culture bon
on peut on peut en débattre mais enfin
c'est quand même c'est quand même pas
quelque chose de particulièrement
choquants je crois qu'un gouvernement de
droite qui a 11 ans de pouvoir continuer
un grand soutien populaire toujours
aujourd'hui décide de subventionner
aussi aussi pas exclusivement aussi les
artistes de droite merci beaucoup fait
en salmacis d'avoir répondu à nos
questions ce matin je rappelle vous êtes
rédacteur en chef du vice grave poste
[Musique]